all right trixie
yes trixie uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally gary indiana
gary and grew up in portage indiana
through
and thomas yeah both parents
um normal middle
class blue collar background
how would you describe your childhood um
confusing but it was it was good my
brother and sister
um little child like but it was
average like nothing no crazy views no
no no not that like what kind of kid
were you in high school
um wild a
class child uh clown like um
yeah i've got a lot of trouble like um
and you were you were trans as a child
um i knew i was why yeah but i didn't
know what it was i just knew
like i was right like um like
by middle school like sixth and seventh
grade i just went talking for
two years like they had me trying to
make me go all these specialists
and i was just confused i don't know
what
um and i would try all these different
personalities like one
for a while it was like preppy and then
there's like
skateboarder and then like rock and then
like um
dress up like hip-hop people like just
all these different things nothing
ever really fit yeah so
did you have friends yeah i had friends
like
later on like because
i was always when i was really young
like up to like high school i
really i didn't really like talk much
kind of like
weird kid like i guess because i
know like anything it seemed like
um teletrade pot like
i knew about it when they had those psas
like after school specials and
for some reason i was like i need smoked
spot and
um i go out we saw the smoking areas
i go out there and with all the the
hoods and
talk about how i got to stone the night
before until someone finally like
got me high that's when i really
well it seems like that's when it came
alive did your
family accept your no
no you had a hard time with that yeah i
pretty hard time because
they nobody in my family or their family
ever
did any of that so and you were born
this way
yeah like um it's even more one of our
like um
i have my room it was my brother's room
was in the basement i had my room
and my sister's room my room it was they
had painted it
blue and had all these like cut out art
deco not art deco but
stencils like sports stars and stuff and
um
i'd always hang out in my sister's room
because it was pink and stuff
and the one here for christmas we all
got those old um dual cassette
iowa stereo systems with um
i i broke mine so i had she used to be
in a room like
i go in her room because i had to use
her stereo like
um yeah so it's just something that
naturally happened for you not that it
wasn't
the result of any abuse turning like
that no and
it was really confusing because you know
porn 72 like in the midwest don't know
about
trans people yeah it's probably
possessed for a while um so
and where'd you go after school where'd
i go after school yeah did you i mean
after
you were done with high school um well i
went on dead to her like
grateful dead um for a long like four
years
i just traveled around because i guess i
tried all those personalities
never my
three good friends they were dads i got
into it but
it was most comfortable it still wasn't
right but
i could grow my hair out i could wear
colors um
a little bit more flamberry and jewelry
and stuff and no more questions oh
you're just happy
um so
yeah like so i did that for a while how
many years has it been were you
you're full-fledged um since i moved out
here because
how many years have you been here um
like two and a half oh so fairly new
yeah like how old are you now um 48.
yeah you uh
so living now in the tenderloin yeah
well six feet right there
tenderloin are you uh do you have
friends here do you feel like you have
friends
i have a couple like i had more before
this but um
a couple of them died like overdosed no
i hate that stuff
um a couple of them left and
the one went just went crazy
like she really lost it which was sad
because she was a genius she had like
five degrees and she was autistic and
she could
within like four words like she could
pick up new languages and like talk them
fluently as
amazing are drugs a part of your life
yeah they always have been like um i was
like i started with weed like that
just it was good for me like um i really
opened up like
it's kind of like this ingredient in
some
point which probably sounds crazy um
and then they made me go to rehab and
find out about all the other drugs so we
have what's the worst thing for me
and then i had which nobody knows about
this this
asgard slaughter disease what is worse
because i
grew so tall so fast my bones outgrew my
tendons and my feet would stick up like
this
and so they went in and they cut little
slits in
the back of my ankle and put in this
metal piece that looked like mushroom
upside down
um it was a progress and he was
really familiar with like pain pills and
stuff so first of all it
overdosed me on the anesthetic like i
was high on just the anesthetic for like
four days and then this doctor had
described me
at 16 a thousand milligram
narcos one every four hours
like for two months and after that like
i was addicted to opiates for the next
15 years
and how do you support yourself now um
right now i'm just on the ga like um
i do work sometimes i don't really like
to anymore as much as i used to like
work the streets
um just because i felt like bad stuff
happened
you've had bad things yeah for some
reason
yeah i'm sure the caliber of
human that picks you up sometimes is
yeah
a problem man i never liked that like
really one of the relationships like
scorpio hopeless romantic when it really
comes to it
but nobody here wants a date like
and it's weird i thought this was this
open-minded open place and
everyone's downloading afraid to be
themselves like
what at least why not you come across i
guess
and maybe it's it's where i'm at too
maybe because
they got to be hard and big problem like
it stopped finally because i'd have
they'd all like threaten me i couldn't
go to the store like
without getting like a death threat a
knife or a gun pulled on me like
there and back so but then because
you're trans
yeah really even in san francisco
but yeah mainly over there and like
through the tenderloin
but then like half of them i'll come try
to knock on my door like two o'clock in
the morning like oh i'll get you high
and
like sex and like yeah but i let them in
and now i smoke all their [ __ ] and then
i send them packing like
are you are you happier here in san
francisco than you were
oh yeah other places yeah i really am
you feel more free here
yeah like because and i could be me like
that's that like i was living the dual
life
um and i waited so long to come out here
because i had two kids and
i waited till they were growing and out
of high school and knew what they were
going to do because
i grew up with a lot of people that only
knew one of their parents and
that that we're abandoned filling and
like
we're kind of messed up about it and i
don't want to do that to them so
and that was hard do your children know
that you're
trans yes they do um and you still
have a good relationship with him um
yeah i still talked to him
not much because the last one of the
last days i did like
when we're done the guy just turned
around and picked me up with my
throat and threw me against the wall and
they pull out this knife was like this
big and
just kept hitting me in the side of the
head who did that
um the last date i was on i haven't done
any dates since then
it's been like three months and took my
phone and everything and
i have been with that phone since then
because i got my name changed through
the court but you can't get into social
security right now because of the
pandemic
so i can't process the whole thing so
you've been homeless before
yeah i've been homeless basically my
whole life like
16 like with mutual like throwing out
i'm leaving but currently you have you
have housing
yeah like i've been there since
last october yeah since i was 16 i was
married for four years
and then i've been homeless since then
until i got this place
what was the best time of your life no
right now because i've been really
living my life like yeah
before it was like facade i was
expecting that answer and
like um it was really good like the last
six years were really hard because like
it's like they were older teenagers
see them like i had them every weekend
so
it was good but then i was just like
well now what am i doing
like because they're gone they're not
coming over like
which i was glad i was like because i
feel weird it's like
all my kids had to do was like at ten
years or so yeah that's glad they have
friends and stuff but
i was lost and that's when i really
started i would go out more
i dressed there on the weekends and go
out to places but
it was there were no gay parts even
really
what's your biggest regret in your life
um cigarettes
it really it is like i hate that like
not crystal meth
no like them you think cigarettes are a
bigger problem than crystal meth
yeah like um i don't stress out about
anything else but
like when i'm out of cigarettes i
everybody [ __ ] like
um yeah i've i've stopped
a bus a couple times like in the middle
road and got on and like shook people
down for cigarettes like
is it bad like all right
and i'll go through all these emotions
like break down cry
like get mad wait what emotions do you
deal with
um i'll get angry like and cry and like
what do i might kill myself like over
cigarettes it's so dumb
because they don't do anything for you
no but like in general
in your life what emotions do you
struggle with oh
depression um really low self-worth
yeah my depression
you've been loved before yeah
yeah a couple times
i just met somebody yesterday and i
really like them
[Music]
who knows is this a one of your
clients or just somebody you met um
somebody met
like um i don't really like money i know
i have to have it like um
but i'm not money hungry like because
most of my was just like survival like
especially back there like oh i need
somewhere to stay like
stay at your house all night too um
but yeah i never really had any money so
just used to it i guess what makes you
happy now
um when i do
do it up like i love to get just i'd sit
there
sometimes all day and just do my face
and
be dressed and just to know that
i can do it and i make myself look good
and
that now that the hormones are really
having an effect
i can look myself in the mirror like um
and i like that like just being yourself
yeah like this i was so confused for so
long and then
and then you can i couldn't do this out
there like
because the one time i was going to go
up to chicago to
the drag show and i was pumping yes and
i just said hey [ __ ] and i turned
around and i got smacked in the head
with two baseball bats
um and then they had put me in a coma
for a chemical induced coma for like
three months until the brain swelling
went down
i'd already teach myself how to walk and
everything after that
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
um not everybody thinks that
the joke like um people are so serious
anymore like
and i just i guess because of trauma i
try to make a lot of things jokes that
are probably
bad timing and like um misunderstood
because everyone's like what are you
talking about i'm like
it's a joke and they end up getting
really mad at me a lot
but i dealt with it all right trixie
well thank you so much for sharing your
story
okay i'm glad you're i'm glad you're
happy
you